tua is a great leader um he's a
competitor he has that fire to him he'll
be a leader no matter where he goes even
when he comes in as a rookie so they're
getting a good play on their hands
they're gonna get a competitor as well
a good offensive lineman who's smart i
got a high football iq a mauler and a
running pass game i try to put people on
the ground as best as i can
[Music]
that's jedrick wills just moments ago at
the podium fresh off the podium here he
is with us at the scouting compound in
indianapolis jedrick wills alabama
offensive lineman self-described mauler
muller when you say mahler give me an
idea of what you can do that is going to
cause you to go out and be a mauler on
the nfl
i like to be a dominant player something
i take pride in
in the run-in pass game like i mentioned
it's something that you got to be in all
aspects of the game just trying to get
in people's faces get my hands inside
and take them as far as i can to the
sideline wherever i can take them do you
prefer run blocking or pass blocking man
i feel like it just depends
there's certain times in the game where
you have to run the clock out and you're
running the football the defense knows
you're running the football it's
something that you have to kind of boss
up and be like all right now it's time
to take over the game and then you have
times like third down where you got to
protect to who knows how long so just
depends on the moment of the game i
guess you were praising two at tonga
villa we had him with us at the super
bowl uh i i think he's great i think
he's a great kid he's got a great
personality he's got a great natural
energy right and it just seems like he's
every bit as good as advertised i mean
he is so he's a really good person even
when people see him like off the field
that that show he puts on is not a show
it's something that's that's really him
he comes from good roots he has a great
family you know he's just all-around
great person give me your best nick
saban story
oh man he he's a jokester that's what a
lot of people don't see they see him
being grumpy and yelling at the media
but he's a good person um i remember one
day i was coming in at practice
and i had on like some some pants that
were like rolled up above my knees a
little bit and yes if i was going
swimming because i had on like
like swim trunks i was like i was like
what
these are jokester now what what is what
is uh is it better to get praised by him
or is it worse i mean what what feels
better uh getting that well let me say
i'm having a hard time here we've been
going what's the stronger emotion for
you thank you matt casey he saved me
we're only on live tv here
stronger emotion feeling that praise
from him or getting that criticism from
him if he gets mad at you for something
thank you again praise is always good um
but i feel like if he's not getting on
you're doing something wrong i see that
with any coach so if you're if you're
out there practicing day in and day out
and he's not criticizing you
something that you're not doing right
yeah uh and and i think it prepares you
for the nfl i'm going to deal with a guy
like that who's been in the nfl as an
assistant coach as a head coach and i
don't think there's any coach in the nfl
other than bill belichick who's as
intense as nick saban right um he's very
detail-oriented
he's a great coach like you said he can
be hard at times but he just he comes
you comes to alabama um and treats you
like a pro something that he trains you
to be day in and day out it's something
that we take pride in now i heard that
you had a formal interview with the
broncos and you were star struck by one
of the individuals who was in the room
right i walked in and saw john elway and
his his whole staff and it was crazy
like growing up seeing him you know just
being like the being the gm for the
broncos then a long time ago being that
quarterback he was like wow i'm really
i'm really here right now let me tell
you
i i have a feeling
jedrick that
he liked that a lot because he's told us
in the past that he's been doing this so
long and been removed from the field for
so long there are guys who don't know
who john elway is when they come in yeah
so he's gotta love it when somebody
comes in and and uh says wow here's john
elway right definitely try to greet him
with like you know how you doing miss
elway i don't think you really like the
mister too much made them feel a little
old
um but uh just trying to greet him and
let him know that like it's crazy that
i'm here right now what's this
experience like when you're in the room
with all those guys and you know they
are scrutinizing everything you say
every move you make every facial
expression everything to try to see is
this guy somebody who's going to be part
of our team i mean from your perspective
what goes on in your brain while you're
trying to answer their questions in a
way that you think is going to make them
realize yeah i'd be a great addition to
your roster when i come in i really just
try to be me um try to be honest trying
to be personable and just let them know
that they're getting everything that
they see i'm really trying to just let
them know that i have a high football iq
i can i can kind of pick things apart
restate things back to them explain who
i am without without being like too
scared or not having the confidence that
i need how many interviews have you had
so far
seven formal and then we have like the
informals where they just kind of speed
date us around um and then i have i have
a full schedule ahead of me coming up
yeah uh doing all the workouts that's
our plan too you gotta everybody cares
about how fast guys run 40 yards without
pads on what's your target i'm trying to
run a cell five uh just trying to trying
to go out there and show that i'm a
freakish athlete have you ever run 40
yards on a football field
maybe like for a touchdown celebration
yeah
maybe not timing when you do that right
yeah maybe on a screen or like chasing
the ball down try to lead block really
just in the moment of the game you don't
realize you're just out there playing
we may not have highlights of you
running down to celebrate a touchdown
but we do have some highlights of
jedrick wills doing some of his mauling
that we talked about earlier check it
out oh oh man that is uh
yeah oh
it for he took it in the face and then
down on the guy that's heist that's way
back in high school when uh you were
sufficiently dominant to get the folks
at alabama's attention but uh
yes impressive impr here we go there's a
little pass blocking and uh
oh man
oh he may have never gotten up after
that one oh and hey you know what that
extra little bit at the end like a lot
of guys would stop
after the first one you don't quit you
keep going after him all the way to the
whistle i assume that's something you
have to do to play in the box um that's
what that's why i love playing the game
um you got to be aggressive you got to
have that main streak get you to play
offensive line and it's something i feel
like i have how do you turn it on and
off because i know that's one of the
challenges for football players that
when it's time to go you almost
transform into someone else but you have
to know to set that aside when it's time
to go be a normal human being right i
feel like as a human being that's not my
personality um i'm not like a super
aggressive person uh some people
describe me as a teddy bear
i guess it is what it is so but when
it's time to go it's time to go
yeah uh well it's it's great it's great
to see those highlights it's great to
see what you've done at alabama it's
gonna be great to see what you do in the
national football league jedrick wills
congratulations on your success and we
look forward to seeing what you do at
the next level yes sir thank you for
having me we'll have more pro football
talk live from the indianapolis scouting
combine right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports